[موسيقى]
مساء الخير انا ميسون ويهد اقدم لكم اخبار
الساعه العناوين
واشنطن تقدموا لي موسكو
بعد ارسال الدبابات يؤكد ان الاشهر
القادمه حاسمه في اوكرانيا
بعد احداث جنين السلطه الفلسطينيه تقرر
وقفه تنسيق الامن مع اسرائيل ووساط
الامريكيه في الطريق
نقابه المحامين اللبنانيه تطلب من القضاه
احترام قسمهم في قضيه انفجار المرفا
لتفادي التحقيق الدولي
وبسبب اقصاء المراه بقرار من طالبان الجوع
والبرد يفتوكاني بالافغان لعدم قدره
المنظمات على العمل
[موسيقى]
بالاشهر القادمه
حتى الان ان الحرب في اوكرانيا دخلت مرحله
جديده فدبابات الغربيه في طريقها الى ساحه
المعركه وزير الدفاع البريطاني اليكس
تشارلز بريطانيا
التي تزودها لاوكرانيا الى البلاد في
نهايه شهر مارس اما وزير الدفاع الالماني
سبيستوريا
سيتم ارسالها الى اوكرانيا في نهايه شهر
مارس
في نهايه الربع الاول من العام لقد قلت في
نهايه شهر مارس على ما اعتقد كل ما اعرفه
هو ان هذا هو الوقت المناسب
لكنقوديه وتزويدها بطائرات افسته عشر شركه
لوكيد مارتن اعلنت استعدادها لتلبيه الطلب
على طائراتها من طراز اف 16 بينما اقترحت
دوله اوروبيه ارسل ذخائر عنقوديه الى
اوكرانيا لمساعدتها في ساحه المعركه دعونا
مشاهدينا الان نتعرف الى ذخائر العنقوديه
وطائرات الحربيه اف 16 سابدا مع ذخائر
العنقوديه هي اسلحه تتكون من حاويه تفتح
في الهواء وتنثر اعدادا كبيره من القنابل
الصغيره او الذخائر الصغيره المتفجره كما
يمكن القاء ذخائر العنقوديه عن طريق
الطائرات او المدفعيه او الغذاء هذا النوع
من ذائر استخدم للمره الاولى في الحرب
العالميه الثانيه ونسبه كبيره من الذخائر
العنقوديا المخزنه في الوقت الحالي سميت
للاستخدام في حرب
المناسبه مشاهدينا هذا النوع من القنابل
محرم دوليا اما طائره افست عشر الامريكيه
تنتمي الى الجيل الرابع من المقاتلات
الحربيه وتعد من اهم الطائرات الحربيه
المقاتله خفيفه الوزن سرعه الطائره تصل
عند اقصى ارتفاع لها الى اكثر من 2400
كيلو متر بالساعه اما سرعتها على مستوى
سطح البحر تصل الى اكثر من 1400 كيلو متر
كذلك يصل متوسط عدد ساعات الطيران للطائره
الواحده خلال عمرها الافتراضي الى حوالي
اثنا عشر الف ساعه الطيران تقريبا يمتلك
هذا النوع من الطائرات قدرات وميزات اعداد
اهمها قدرتها على اصابه الهدف بكل دقه
سواء في البحر او الجو بالاضافه الى
قدرتها على التعبئه الوقود اثناء الطيران
وقدرتها على الطيران للنساء فاتن بعيده
وفي اي ظروف جويه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في اول رد فعل على اقتراح تثبيت اوكرانيا
بالذخائر وطائرات افسته عشر وصف رئيس
الوفد الروسي في محادثات فيينا حول الامن
العسكريه والسيطره على التسلق قسن جابر
وصف طائره اف 16 والطائرات من 29 باسلحه
القرن الماضي وقال انه لا يستبعد ان يزود
الغرب اوكرانيا بهذه الاسلحه اما الكريم
فاعلن ان ارسال دول الغربيه
[موسيقى]
ليه متابعه التطورات على الارض ينضم اليه
من اكياس حذيفه عادل مراسل العربيه من
موسكو ايضا عبد الجواد الرشد مراسل
العربيه اهلا بكما سابدا معك حذيفه ابرز
التطورات الميدانيه اين تركز القصف وما هي
الحصيله اليوم حصيله القتلى والجرحى
نعم مساء الخير ميسون لك وللزميل عبد
الجواد في الحقيقه عمليه القصف الواسع
واسعه النطاق التي طالت 11 منطقه في
الاراضي الاوكرانيه تركزت طبعا في اولا في
في الولايات الوسط وكذلك في الغرب في
الولايات الجنوبيه وكذلك في الشرق البلاد
في الحقيقه كما قال فاليري زولوجي اطلقت
القوات الروسيه 55 صاروخ النحو الاراضي
الاوكرانيه استطاع الدفاع الجوي الاوكراني
ان يسقط منها
صاروخا عدد ضحايا حتى الان بحسب هيئه
الطوارئ الحكوميه اعلنت عن 11 مصابا و11
قتيلا في المناطق المختلفه وطبعا ايضا على
يعني في الحديث عن الجبهات القتال تحديدا
اعلنت هيئه الاركان المشتركه عن ان
التركيز الاساسي للقوات الروسيه كان
تحديدا في منطقه في منطقه صفاته وكريم عد
ذلك همم بالفشل
جميع الهجمات التي قامت بها القوات
الروسيه كذلك كان هنالك محاوله او هجمه في
منطقه اوغل الدار وبقيه الجبهات هي كانت
عباره عن ضربات براجمات الصواريخ ميسون بن
سبه سوسيه عبد الجواد هل وزاره الدفاع
تحدثت عن القصف الذي طال المدن الاوكرانيه
اليوم
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تطرق اليوم الى
الضربات المكثفه التي صعدت موسكو منذ ليله
الامس بعد الاعلان عن امداد كيف الدبابات
الغربيه طبعا البيان تطرق على الحديث عن
تحييد عشرات المقاتلين والجنود
الاوكرانيين في مناطق مختلفه لعلى ابرز ما
جاء في هذا البيان هو اسقاط مقاتلتين من
طراز سوء خمسه وعشرون في ثانيه وفي كليدار
طبعا الحديث اليوم والشغل
لقراءه العسكريه في البلاد والسياسيه هو
العمليات العسكريه والقتاليه في المناطق
المحيطه ببغمه على ما يبدو ان المنطقه
هناك الان يعني المعارك فيها اصبحت من
العيار الثقيل موسكو تتحدث عن الدخول في
مواجهات وحرب على الارض مع المقاتلين
الاوكرانيين هي قوات
وافقنا طبعا تلعب دور محوري في تلك
المنطقه ايضا طبعا بين وزاره الدفاع
التطرق الى ضرب وتعطيل وتدمير العديد من
النقاط الحيويه العسكريه التابعه للقوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه منها على سبيل المثال
محطات او اماكن اللي ضربها اطلاق الصواريخ
طبعا
يدور الحديث هي النقطه الاساسيه اليوم
الايام القديمه القليله القادمه كما يتوقع
قره السياسه
والخطط العسكريه في البلاد ستشهد هذه
المنطقه معارك قاسيه على شكل تلك التي
حدثت في سندار في نقطه اخيره طبعا على
الصعيد السياسي ميسون لابد من ذكر ان
يكرمني اليوم خرج بتصريح على لسان المتحدث
الرسمي
وقال بان موسكو تعتبر بشكل مباشر واشنطن
وحلفائها بمبدا كيف بالاسلحه الغربيه
تعتبرهم شركاء مباشره في هذا الصراع
المسلح في الاراضي الاوكرانيا ساعود اليك
عبد الجواد لانتحدث عن هذه التخوفات من
قبل روسيا بتزويد اكياف بالصواريخ وطائرات
افست عشر ولكن دعنا نذهب مجددا الى حذيفه
لنعرف منه اكثر عن تفاصيل اللقاءات التي
قام بها الرئيس لينسك اليوم
الرئيس الاوكراني فلاديميرسي اليوم اجرى
اجتماع وصفه بالهام مع هيئه الاركان
العامه المشتركه للجيش الاوكراني وهذا
الاجتماع
سوف يقوم بها الجيش الاوكراني خاصه مع
طبعا توريد الاسلحه الغربيه
والبطاريات طبعا باتريوت وغيرها سوف تكون
هنالك اجراءات جديده للجيش الاوكراني
لمواجهه الضربات الصاروخيه كذلك اجتمع
طبعا بالقاده الميدانيين للقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه وناقشه الوضع في الجبهه بكثير
من التفصيل كما قال الوضع تحديدا في باقه
وايضا ناقصه توريد الاسلحه وطريقه توزيع
هذه الاسلحه همم على القوات المقاتله في
الجبهات المختلفه حذيفه 30 ثانيه لزميلنا
عبد الجواد ايضا نعرف منه هذه التخوفات
لروسيا هل تحدثت عنها بخصوص احتمال تثبيت
اكياس بطائرات 16 والصواريخ بعيده المدى
لا يمكن طبعا اخفاء قلق موسكو من تزويد
الغرب
يعني لاوكرانيا بالسلاح الحديث المتطور
قضيه الدبابات يعني هي قضيه عاديه كما ترى
موسكو يمكن التعامل معها وتدمير هذه
الدبابات لكن ما يقلق موسكو بشكل كبير هي
المقاتلات الامريكيه اف 16 التي قد يتم
تزويد كيف بها خلال الاشهر القادمه
والصواريخ بعيده المدى التي قد تحول
الصراع وتنتقل به الى مرحله اكثر خطوره
بحيث يمكن لهذه الصواريخ انت طالب شبه
جزيره القرم او مناطق في العمر او الداخل
الروسي لذلك طبعا تخوفات موسكو من هذا
الموضوع هي كبيره لا يمكن الغائها لكن كما
تتحدث مصر حتى هذه اللحظه بانها ستعمد
مباشره الى تدمير هذا السلاح في حال تم
تثبيته به ان كان طائرات وان كان دبابات
وان كان صواريخ بعيده شكرا لك كل هذه
التفاصيل من موسكو زميلنا عبد الجواد
الرسمي مراسل العربيه كما اشكر حذيفه عادل
مراسل العربيه من كاف على كل هذه التفاصيل
والمعلومات
منذ بدايه الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا في
فبراير الماضي انهكت الضربات الروسيه بنيت
اوكرانيا التحتيه حيث ارتفع اجمالي
والاضرار التي لحقت بها الى ما يقرب من
1838 مليار دولار متابع
[موسيقى]
اظهر مقطع فيديو لقطات من عمل الروبوت
ماركر الذي سيشارك في الحرب في اوكرانيا
الى جانب القوات الروسيه حيث كشفت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه انه سيتمكن من اكتشاف وضرب
المعدات الاوكرانيه تلقائيا بما في ذلك
دبابات عبر رمز الامريكيه وليفارد
الالمانيه
[موسيقى]
اختي حماتي ومداهمات مجمع شهدتها محافظه
جنين منذ بدايه العام من قبل الجيش
الاسرائيلي اخر هذه الاقتحامات كانت اليوم
والتي اسفرت عن مقتل تسعه اشخاص وعشرات
الجرح الفلسطينيين بحسب وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه
اليوم بدخول سياره المدنيه كانت تقل قوات
خاصه اسرائيليه وكانت تهدف لاعتقالي
مطاردين وبعد كشف انها لتخليص القوه
الخاصه التي عالقت في المخيم استخدم الجيش
الاسرائيلي قوات العسكريه كبيره مات سببا
في مواجهه عنيفه اما وفق الروايه
الاسرائيليه فالعمليه تستهدفت مطلوبين من
حركه الجهاد الاسلامي كانوا يخططون لتنفيذ
عمليه كبيره في الداخل الاسرائيلي هذا
واندلعت اشتباكات بين الفلسطينيين والقوات
الاسرائيليه في رام الله ادت الى ثلاث
اصابات خطيره وايضا الى مقتل شاب واردنا
على هذه مواجهات في مخيم جنين افادت وكاله
الانباء الفلسطينيه بانزلاع مواجهه اخرى
بين مواطنين وقوات اسرائيليه في الخليل
وطولكرم بدقه الغربيه الوكاله اشارت ايضا
الى اعلان اضراب شامل في الضفه الغربيه
والقدس حدادا على ارواح قتل الهجوم
الاسرائيليه على مدينه جنين
وعلى ضوء هذه الاشتباكات التي شهدها مخيم
جنين قال المتحدث باسم الرئاسه الفلسطينيه
قررت وقفه تنسيق الامني مع اسرائيل
والتوجهها بملف جنين للجنائيه الدوليه
قررت القياده الفلسطينيه في اجتماعه
الطارئ اليوم ما يلي
في ضوء العدوان المتكرر على ابناء الشعبنا
والضرب بعرض الحائط للاتفاقات الموقعه بما
فيها الامنيه
نعتبر ان التنسيق الامني مع حكومه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لم يعد قائما اعتبارا
من الان
ان التنسيق الامني ما حكومه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لم يعد قائما اعتبارا من الان
فعلا اكدت الخارجيه الامريكيه بحثها عن
تمريرات من اسرائيل حول اقتحام مخيم جنين
كما دعت لخفض التصعيد الخارجيه الامريكيه
علقت ايضا على وقف تنسيق الامني بين
السلطه الفلسطينيه واسرائيل بانه قرار غير
صائب داعيه السلطه لاعاده هذا التنسيق
الامني مع اسرائيل وكانت الخارجيه
الامريكيه قد اعلنت في وقت سابق ان الوزير
انتم لينكن سيبداوا يوم الاحد المقبل
زياره الى المنطقه تشمل مصر واسرائيل
والضفه الغربيه مضيفه ان جوله في المنطقه
ستكون مخصصه للتوتر بين الاسرائيليين
والفلسطينيين كما سيدعوا لانهاء العنف
خلال جولتي
قوه اسرائيليه خاصه تدخل بزي المدني مخيم
جنين عند السابعه صباحا
بعد انكشاف امرها وتعرضها لاطلاق النار من
مسلحين فلسطينيين
اجتاح الجيش الاسرائيلي المخيم واوقع عددا
من الضحايا بين قتيل وجريح
بعد ساعه على انسحاب الجيش الاسرائيلي من
مخيم جنين بقيت دخان المتقاعد من هذا
المنزل شاهد على اربع ساعات من الاشتباكات
والانفجارات التي عمت احياء مخيم جنين
خلال اجتياح الجيش الاسرائيلي للمخيم
ومحاصره المنازل توصلوا هنا في الدور اللي
هون وفي الدور الاتحاد
الدور وبلغ شو اطلاق انا ارجع على البيت
احتجز في البيت اللي تحت هذا البيت
احتجزوا فيه اصحاب البيت
وقعدوه مسكر علوم البيت وبلشوا من البيت
نفسه يضربوا ونرجع البيت هذا الصواريخ
شيعوا من سقطوا برصاص الجيش الاسرائيلي
فيما لا يزال العشرات يتلقون العلاج في
المشاكل الفلسطينيه وصفت جراح اربعه منهم
بالحرجه
لتصدر المشهد في الاراضي الفلسطينيه في
عمليه وصفت بالاعنا في منذ تولي الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الجديده زمام الحكم في
اسرائيل ما ينظروا بتصحيح خطير على صعيد
الصراع الاسرائيلي الفلسطيني
العربيه
[موسيقى]
في اخبار الساعه لدينا ايضا المعارضه
التركيه تعتبر ترشيحها اردوغان للرئاسه
مخالفا للدستور
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد عوده قضيه مرفا بيروت
الى الواجهه اعاده معها ازمه قضائيه حربها
ستخيم على التحقيق مجددا بعد ان ارجع عده
مرات اهالي ضحايا انفجار بيروت نظم
واعتصاما امام وزاره العدل بالتزامن مع
اجتماعنا لمجلس القضاء الاعلى للبحث في
تطورات التحقيقات الثلج
في بيروت مواجهه بين قوات الامن ومحتاجين
ما دفع الجيش لارسال في اعتزازه الى محيط
وزاره العدل في العاصمه بعد ان حاول
المحتجون اقتحام مقر الوساره نقابه
المحامين اللبنانيين قالت ان على القضاه
في البلاد احترام قسمهم لتفادي اللجوء الى
تحقيق دولي في قضيه انفجار ما الفرق بيروت
كما تحدث نقابه المحامين اللبنانيين عن
قرار النائب العام باطلاق سراح الموقوفنا
بقضيه انفجار المرفق وقالت انه غير
قانونيه
مشهد ماساوي ظل لقصر عدلي بيروت عكس الدرك
الذي وصلت اليه ازمه لبنان على مختلف
السعودي والتي طاولت العدل واسيسه
ما جرى امام هذا الصرح كان قد صبقه تراشق
قضائي بين المحقق العدلي في قضيه انفجار
المرفق طارق البيطار ومدعي عام التمييز
غسان عويدات على خلفيه اطلاق الاخير صراحه
جميع الموقوفين
على الملف العدلي اللي هو ملك بالنهايه
مذكرات توقيف صادر عن المحقق العدل اليوم
انه موقوفين باشاره من النيابهم بالطريقه
التركيه يتم اخلاء سبيلهم عن طريق النيابه
عن طريق اليوم تم الاستلام على صلاحيه رغم
انه قرارات القادم هي قرارات نافذ غير
قابل الاستئنانيه
لقصر العدل باهالي ضحايا انفجار وتحول
المشهد الى هرج ومرج وتدافع بعد تعرض عدد
من نواب البرلمان الذين حضروا تضامنا
للمضادات والتهجم من قبل مرافق وزير العدل
بلد ما بيقوم ما ممكن يثبت اصل ما في فص
السلطات واذا ما بيوقف التدخل السياسي
بالقضاء هذا اللي حاولنا ان الليل اليوم
حولنا نقول له لوزير العدل هو وزير وصايه
وعنده صلاحيات لما بشوف في خروقات كثير
كبيره بالقضاء يقدر يتصرف طبعا
المليشيا اللي بتحمي وزير العدل
اتصرفت مع انه بطريقه اقل ما يقال فيه انه
وحشيه ما اطلع بالرئيس انه نعرف شو صار
المطلق بالرئيس انه هالناس اللي كانوا
قاعدين بشغلهم من بيتهم قتلوهم ببيوتهم
بدام بارد وهلا عم يقضوا على عيال لانه
على اهلهم وعلى القضيه ويزيحوا همم القاضي
بيطار على جنب نحن
موجودين وهي دائما
اعتبروارات
اقتحام من نفذها المعتصمون باتجاه قصر
العدل لم ينعقد مجلس القضاء الاعلى بحجه
رفض ضغط الشارع وتدخل النواب سقوط مدون
سجل لدور القضائي في لبنان بما يعنيه من
ارساء العدل والعداله وهيبتهما او بما
يمثله من عمود اساسيين من اعمده حول ما
يطفي صوره قادمه على مال الامور في القادم
من الايام رينادويه العربيه بيروت
وفي ملف المرفق ايضانا ورغم قرار منعه من
السفر فوجئ اللبنانيون بخبر مغادره الرئيس
مصلحه الامن والسلامه في مرفا بيروت محمد
زياد العوف الى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه التي يحمل جنسيتها بعد اخلاء
سبيله امس ليله مصادر تقول ان مغادره
العوف جاءت قبل توقيع مدعي عام التمييز
غسان عويدات قرار منع السفر عن الموقوفين
المخلص دينهم بمعنى ان عويدات اعلن عن منع
السفر لكنه لم يوقع القرار قبل مغادره
العوف لبنان
دعونا الان مشاهدينا ان نعود سويا لما حدث
بتاريخ الرابع من اغسطس من العام 2020 اي
منذ لحظه انفجار مرفق بيروت يعتقد ان سبب
الانفجار هو حريق نشب في احد المستودعات
والتسع مسببا انفجار مئات الاصنام من
نترات الامونيوم المواد الكيميائيه هذه
كانت متجهه في الاصل الى موزمبيق علمتني
سفينه مستاجره من روسيا لكنها سوودرت عام
2013 مكتب التحقيقات الفيدراليه الامريكيه
خلصا الى ان كميه التلات الامونيوم التي
انفجرت هي حمص الكميه المقدره ب
2754 طنا ما عزت الشكوك بشان فقدان كميات
كبيره من الشحنه اما من كان يعلم بهذه
الشحنه هم مسؤولون لبنانيون كبار من بينهم
الرئيس السابق ميشيل عون ورئيس الوزراء
انذاك حسن الدياب كما ذكرت منظمته من رئيس
ان مسؤولين امينه وحكميين كبار كانت لديهم
تقارير عن الخطر لكنهم لن يقوم باي تحرك
اما بالنسبه لمسار التحقيق بقضيه المرفق
فواجه معوقات منذ اللحظه الاولى بسبب
الضغط السياسي على القضاء اول المحققين
القادم صوان وجهتها
لثلاثه وزراء سابقين وحسان دياب بالاهمال
لكنه وجهها بعد ذلك ضغوطا قويه وابعده
بعدها من القضيه في فبراير 20 21 بعد ان
شكا اثنان من الوزراء السابقين وهما علي
حسن خليل وغازي زعيتر من تجاوز السلطاتهم
اما البيطار الذي عدنا خلفا لصوان سعى
لاستجواب للشخصيات البارزه من بينها خليل
وسيدر حتى وصلت تحقيق الى مرحله من
النسيان التامه في 20 22 الى الحين استانف
البيطار تحقيقه هذا الاسبوع بناء على راي
القانوني ووجهها لاتهامات لمسؤولين بينهم
مدير عام الامن العام اللواء عباس ابراهيم
لم يلاحق البطار اي من اعضاء حزب الله لكن
الاخير جنه حمله شرسه ضده بعد ما سعى
لاستجواب خلفاء له
[موسيقى]
من بيروت الى الرزق وزير العدل اللبنانيه
الاسبق استرزق اهلا بكم معنا ماذا تعني
فوضى التحقيق بانفجار مرفا بيروت التي ادت
الى هذه الازمه في القضاء اللبنانيه
التي تقوم عليها الدوله اللبنانيه اضافه
الى
المؤسسات المؤسسه الامنيه بانشاء
الجيش اضافي الى الجيش الرسمي هو
المقاومه تحت ستار المقاومه وايضا تدمير
المؤسسه الماليه فقدت العمله اللبنانيه
الليره اللبنانيه قيمتها الكليه وايضا
انهيار وتدمير
بسعر مؤسسات بدء برئاسه الجمهوريه التي هي
شاغره منذ فتره طويله
وذلك
الدوله اللبنانيه التي يسعى اليه فريق
النسور الخاصه
غير مسبوقه في لبنان هل حصل ذلك قبل
لا لم يحصل ذلك من قبل بالحقيقه
قد يكون القاضي
الاول
قد يعني تسرع بقراراته ولكن هذا لا يعفي
المدعي العام التمييزي من تسريحه في ما
قام به اليوم والامس وكل ذلك يستعجل في
تدمير القضاء اللبناني رغم انه يوجد قضاه
لكن المؤسسه كمؤسسه قضي عليها
المخوله
لحل هذه الازمه وخاصه بانها تطال مؤسسه
مهمه وركيزه اساسيه في اي دوله بالعالم
وهو القضاء
انا ارجو ان تسالي رئيس الحكومه التي هي
مبدئيا تشفر رئاسه الجمهوريه
بالوكاله
لم نسمع اليوم نجيب الميقاتي ليتنا سمعنا
احد وزراء المسؤولين في هذه الحكومه
ويعطي موقف
الراي العام اللبناني قالوش الصحيحه
الشعب اللبناني والمجتمع اللبناني اليوم
مجتمع متروك لا تديره دوله
وهي مسؤوليه كبيره لكل الذين يشاركون في
ما يسمى الحكم
مباشر بانه على القضاه احترام قسمهم
لتفادي اللجوء الى تحقيق دولي هل نحن
سنذهب الى التحقيق الدولي قريبا
هل نحن امام تحقيق دولي اذا بقيت هذه
الفوضى في القضاء اللبناني
في حال فقدان وتبخر ما تبقى من المؤسسات
اللبنانيه اين هي هذه المؤسسات اللبنانيه
الحكومه غائبه والرئاسه الجمهوريه غير
موجوده
يعني لماذا لا توجه الاسئله اليوم لما
تبقى من الحكومه التي تدعي هي ممارسه
الرئاسه
في غياب الرئيس وذلك ابو موسى
ولكن الاجابات هي المشكله وليست الاسئله
على كل حال اريد ايضا ان اتوقف عن هذه
النقطه موضوع الجدل حول السفر زياده العفو
قيل بانه تم اخلاء سبيل الموقفين ولكن
منعوا من السفر ومن ثم بعد ساعات قليله
وجدناه في الطائره متوجه الى الولايات
المتحده
انا اسف لكل الخبر الذي
قيل انه المدعي العام اخلص سبيله بناء طلب
احدى السفارات ايا كانت السفرات ومهما
عزما السفاره
التي تفكرين فيها انا اسف ان يتاثر المدعي
العام بهذه الطلبات
وهذا الامر غير قانوني صحيح
من دول الخارج
على الانضمام الينا اليوم عشان رزق وزير
العدل اللبنانيه الاسبق ونشكر مشاركه
[موسيقى]
اصدرت المعارضه التركيه بيانا تقول فيها
ان الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان لا يمكنه
الترشح لولايه رئاسيه ثالثه دون موافقه
البرلمان وذلك بحسب الدستور واشاره
المعارضه الى ان اعلن اردوغان الترشح
لولايه ثالثه مخالف من الدستور كما اكدت
المعارضه انها لا تزال تتشاور الاختيار
مرشحها للرئاسه
[موسيقى]
انها رئيس الوزراء باحمد زياره الى
الخرطوم استغرقت ساعه ناقش خلال لها عدد
من المواضيع الخلافيه بينها سد النهضه
والحدود فضلا عن اجرائه عدد من اللقاءات
مع القوى السياسيه لتقليب وجوهات النظر لن
يعقوب معها التفاصيل
علامتني هذه الطائره وصل وفد الاثيوبيين
ضخم الى الخرطوم يقوده رئيس الوزراء باحمد
الرجل الذي جاء مبتسما وحاملا عددا من
الملفات في حقيبته قضى يوما طويلا مليئا
بلقاءات والمباحثات شحيحا في المقترحات
صافره البدايه كانت مع رئيس مجلس السياده
الذي اكد اتفاقهم على كافه القضايا
المتعلقه بسد النهضه وان يحتكم الطرفان
الى الوثائق في ما يتعلق بموضوع الحدود
مكتتما حديثه بثناء موهود على علاقات
البنات
[موسيقى]
وهي كلها نريدها ان تصب في مصلحه الشعبين
لتقويه هذه العلاقه بين الدولتين الجارتين
الشقيقتين
بعيدا عن الخلافات الخارجيه قريبا الى
المشاكل الداخليه لقاءات المطوله اجراها
ابي احمد مع الكتل والقوه السياسيه بمختلف
اتجاهاتها لقاءات تستهدف الاستماع اكثر من
تقديم حلول جديده
المشكله هي الطريقه التي تمت بها
تشكيل الوضع الانتقالي
وتحويل هذا الوضع الى صراع الى صراع
للاحزاب على السلطه الانتقاليه
تتزامن محاولات ابي احمد لاحداث توافق بين
الاطراف السودانيه مع مساعي تقودها
القاهره بين القوى السياسيه والتي من
المقرر ان يغادر معظمها الى مصر نهايه
الشهر الجاري يبدو واضحا ان مسعى كل دوله
يسير في اتجاه مختلف
من اشكال التنافس المصري الاثيوبي على
الاراضي السودانيه ومحاوله كل طرف من
الاطراف بان تكون له اليد الطول في حل
الازمه السودانيه
احمد استمرت ساعات فهل تستقبل اللقاءات
التي جرت في الخرطوف اديس ابابا لاحداث
توافق القريب ام انها ستنتقل الى القاهره
لاحداث اختراق جديد لن يعقوب العربيه
الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
اعرب سكان العاصمه الافغانيه كابول
المغطاه بالجليد والثلوج عن قلقهم بشان
الطقس البارد الذي اجترحها معظم انحاء
البلاد حيث انخفض درجات الحراره الى ناقص
34 درجه مئويه ما ادى ايضا الى تفاقم
الازمه الاقتصاديه التي تواجهها افغانستان
واستطبت ان في المساعدات الانسانيه بعد
سيطره طالبان على البلاد
سته ملايين شخص في افغانستان يعيشون
المجاعه ويواجهون مستوى مطارئا من انعدام
الامن الغذائي
على الاهتمام الجاد بنا لان الشتاء شديد
البروده هذا العام والناس يموتون
ولا منقد واطفالنا ليس لديهم ملابس دافئه
يرتدونها
خلال الصباح الباكر والليل يصبح الطقس
شديد البروده معظم طلابنا لا يستطيعون
النوم ياتي بعد الطلاب الاكبر سنا ولكن
الصغار لا يستطيعون ذلك
تسلم يا ميمه
نشهد بروده شديده الناس يواجهون مشاكل
كثيره لما اولا غاز الناس يحاولون مواجهه
هذه التحديات
الامم المتحده منير اكرم ان العالم لا
يستطيع مواجهه حركه طالبان لان الحركه هي
حقيقه افغانستان ويجب التعامل معها وسرح
مندوب باكستان لدى الامم المتحده في
مقابله مع بي بي سي انه لا يمكن الاستمرار
في مواجهه طالبان فهم واقع افغانستان وهي
تسيطر على البلاد باكملها لذا يجب ان
نتعامل معها كما دعم منير اكرم الى
استراتيجيه جديده للتعامل واقناع حركه
طالبان بالاهتمام بمخاوه المجتمع الدولي
بشان الحقوق السياسي
في اخبار الساعه سنتابع بعض لحظات اليابان
تنجح في اطلاق قمر صناعي لمراقبه تحركات
بيوم بيانجل العسكريه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد تكثف شرطه مدينه
فيلادلفيا في ولايه فانسلفانيا الامريكيه
جهودها للعطور على امراه ارتكبت جريمه قتل
الراحه ضحيتها طالب من سعودي
هذا الاسبوع الطالب المغدور يدعى الوليد
الغريبي يبلغ من العمر 25 عاما ووفقا
للشرطه تم العثور على جثته يوم الاثنين
مصابا بطانه في الرقبه داخل المبنى الذي
يقطن فيه
من بنسلفانيا مراسله العربيه للتسليمات
اهلا بك معنا ماذا لدينا من تفاصيل حتى
الان
ميسون نحن الان امام منزل وليد الغريبي
الذي قتل فيه يوم الاثنين الماضي
التحقيقات لازالت جاريه حتى اللحظه
دعيني اشير بانه هذا هو الماندر الذي قتل
فيه وليد الغريبي وتحديدا في الطابق
الثالث من هذا المنزل
هذا الحي الذي يتواجد فيه المنزل هو من
الاحياء الفقيره التي تعد نسبيا في مدينه
فيلادلفيا همم يسكن فيه دمه داخل المنخفض
حقيقه همم
وايضا همم تسكن فيه غالبيه همم السكان
امريكيين همم من اصول افريقيه همم قبل
دقائق تحديدا ميسون تواصلنا مع صاحبه هذا
المبنى التي ذكرت لنا بانه همم هذا
الحادثه التي حصلت يوم الاثنين وانها تعرف
وليد الغريبي وذكره لنا بانه همم ولد خلوق
جود جدا همم هو مستاجر في هذا المنزل
وتحدثت عنه باسهاب وكانت تبكي لانها خسرت
كما ذكرت صديق رائع وذكرت ايضا بانه همم
نيكول ميري التي ارتكبتها المتهمه بارتكاب
هذه الجريمه كانت مستاجره من قبل همم
الموقع الذي يسمح باشاره المنازل لايام
عده نيكول مريء استاجرت همم غرفه في هذا
المنزل لمده 18 يوما ولم تكمل 18 يوما همم
اعتبرت ملكه هذا المنزل بانه همم ميريكان
لديها مشكله مع وليد الغريبي لم تعرف
سببها ملكه المنزل لم تحدثنا عن تفاصيلها
طلبت
همم منها بانه همم فقط ان الطول بانه همم
وليد كان من افضل الزبائن الذين تعاملت
معهم في هذا المنزل وقبل دقائق ايضا ميسون
التواصلت معنا الشرطه
فيلادلفيا ومكتب المختص بمتابعه هذه
القضيه تحديدا وارسل لنا همم بريد
الكتروني ذكر بانه لا
نتبع المعلومات المتداوله حول هذا هذا هذه
القضيه تحديدا لانها غير صحيحه وانه سيتم
مشاركتنا بكل التفاصيل الصحيحه فور انتهاء
التحقيقات اذا التحقيقات لا زالت جاريه
حتى اللحظه همم نيكول ميري همم لا زالت لا
زالت هاربه من قبل السلطات حتى اللحظه
وحتى همم بانه الشرطه شاركتنا الصوره
الخاصه
للمتحمه وايضا ب همم نمره لوحه
ساره الخاصه بالمتهمه من الجدير ذكره همم
ميسون بانه هذا الحي همم ليس امنا تماما
وان عناصر الشرطه دائما ما تتواجد فيه حتى
انهم طلبوا منا بانه بان نبقى تحت انظارهم
لانهم لا يستطيعوا التامين سلاماتنا حتى
همم نكون تحت انظاره
وابقوا حذرين نشكرك على كل هذه المعلومات
على كل هذه التفاصيل من بانسلفانيا
شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
بعد عامين من وضع الشركات بل الشركه
المالكه لمنصه الفيسبوك وانستغرام حاضر
على حسابات الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب تنوي شركه توميتا السماحه للترامب
بالعوده مجددا الى موقع فيسبوك وانستغرام
للتواصل الاجتماعي القريبا وقال الرئيس
متى للشؤون العالميه في بيان رسمي ان
الجمهوريه يجب ان يكون قادرا على سماع ما
يقوله سياسيوها لكن كيف علق ترامب على هذا
القرار
[موسيقى]
اخبار تحت نذكر بالعناوين
تقدموا لموسكو عرضا للحوار
وبعد احداث جنين السلطه الفلسطينيه تقرر
وقفه تنسيق الامني مع اسرائيل
نقابه المحامين اللبنانيه تطلب من القضاه
احترام قسمهم في قضيه انفجار المرفا
لتفادي التحقيق الدولي و بسبب اقصاء
المراه بقرار من طالبان الجوع والبرد
يفتكاني بالافغان
اشكركم طيب المتابعه في امان الله
[موسيقى]